I once saw a guy getting nailed in the  Harriet you took them through the duck  doctor took it out he was fine did he  know them are they are they sub second  is this new delivery safely contained  comes in a foolproof locked silver case  and it's worth your life  hey fellas this is my business  you ruined my dream and I'll shoot you  in the ass  you're wrong and that's a Diablo that's  East we walk it to the desert I grew up  out here man you must present the case  to the master and then you have to  unlock it like so  where's the case Rana if it's a bomb are  you sure we should keep it it's not a  bone [ __ ] I said one in London for 69  million no I like a [ __ ] towel mm-hmm  don't be such a good guy exactly the  point  so you say for two years we've been  driving around in this piece of crap and  we didn't have any seat belt